throughout the 80s and 90s Dana Carvey
was a towering presence in comedy and he
was the unequal star of Saturday Night
Live during his 1986 to 1993 tenure
oh isn't that special
from the church lady to Garth to his
unhinged impressions of politicians like
George HW Bush Harvey was king that's
great but what has he been up to
recently heart problems in the 90s
Carvey reported suffering terrible chest
pain doctors discovered that it was
related to blood not flowing properly to
his heart good man look at this x-ray
AHA looks like a pig look at that thing
still the terrible chest pains continued
even after multiple angioplasty and a
double bypass further tests revealed
that his doctor had made a terrible
mistake he bypassed the wrong artery
Carvey had no choice but to repeat the
painful and elaborate double bypass
surgery but with a different doctor
Harvey sued the original heart surgeon
for 7.5 million dollars and settled out
of court in 2000 being the victim of a
botched surgery understandably sidelined
Carvey for a while family man after he
left SNL in 1993 Harvey starred in a
string of what he calls awful movies
including trapped in paradise and the
master of disguise at the time he
realized that he didn't want to be away
from his two very young sons Dex and Tom
he told the a/v Club that he even ended
up bringing his kids to the sets of his
movie saying quote it felt weird and
awkward to hand the kid to a nanny so
that kind of went out the window one son
had a lot of ear infections and the
other one got the flu and quote during
the filming of Wayne's World 2 one of
his sons became upset with his long
blonde Garth Algar wig and started
sobbing Harvey took those incidents as
cues to focus on his family full-time
and moved his wife and kids to quote a
small town with trees and quotes in
Northern California Harvey didn't tend
to his career for two full years Dex and
Tom Harvey are now both in their
twenties and are both pursuing careers
in comedy just
they're dead near-misses he could have
been a player on late-night TV in the
early 90s late-night host David
Letterman jumped over to CBS to go
head-to-head with a Tonight Show
so NBC tasks SNL creator and executive
producer Lorne Michaels with finding a
host he looks to his SNL cat-car be
amiable versatile and one of the most
popular cast members in years was
offered the job
NBC thought it was such a lock that they
gave him 1 million dollars and a Beatles
album signed by all four Beatles worth
$400,000 just to consider the offer
Harvey even landed on the cover of TV
Guide as Letterman's heir apparent it
took a year for Carvey to decide not to
do late nights because he didn't want to
commit to a nightly show it wasn't the
first time he passed on a job either the
1995 action movie bad boys was first
offered to Carvey and his SNL co-star
John Lovett at the time it was titled
bulletproof hearts and it could have
been a huge hit for Carvey at the peak
of his fame but then director Michael
Bay at the time best known for making
music videos joined the project and
convinced producers to make it a
youth-oriented
action flick carve Ian Lovitz did a
screen test which Carvey felt was so
inappropriate for him that he left a
movie Carvey even tried to fall back on
one of his popular recurring SNL
sketches European bodybuilders Hans and
Franz I'm on a diet frogs and we want to
pop you love SNL writer Robert Smigel
worked on the screenplay for a big
screen adventure with Harvey Kevin
Nealon and Conan O'Brien oh and it was
also a musical and then their muscles
were going to dance like boom boom boom
boom
I'll get a flexible Dan material in 20 a
substantial role was written for Arnold
Schwarzenegger playing himself as well
as an Austrian grandmother but he
dropped out of cons and Franz the
girlie-man dilemma after the failure of
the similarly self-effacing Last Action
Hero
after that the project collapsed these
were even Carvey's earliest or worst
brushes with the fickle world of
Hollywood solo sketches just two years
after leaving the comedy confines of SNL
in 1994 Carvey returned to TV with the
data Carvey show while it was critically
acclaimed and became a cult hit among
comedy nerds was a commercial disaster
ABC scheduled to air immediately after
its family-friendly mega hit home
improvement what they got was wild weird
and just a little dark everything
home-improvement wasn't the days are
rushing by children it'll be over before
you know it the show honed the talents
of a lot of the most important comedy
writers and performers of the last 20
years including writer Charlie Kaufman
the office co-creator Greg Daniels
community writer Dino stamatopoulos and
head writer louis c.k and then there
were these guys ratings dropped after
the first episode and the Dana Carvey
show was canceled after seven weeks it
took nearly 15 years for Carvey to
attempt sketch comedy again in 2010 he
and Dana Carvey show writer spike
feresten created a series for Fox called
spoof which was completely pre-taped and
didn't feature any in studio pieces or a
live audience
Fox paid for a pilot but opted not to
order it to a full series again it was
very very weird
patrocle patrocle finally in 2016
Harvey starred on a game show befitting
his talent USA's first impressions was
Dana Carvey was a competition show that
sought out America's most skilled a
mature voice impressionist with a cash
prize of $100,000 car B served as the
show's expert in residence and both he
and Freddie Prinze jr. judged and
coached the contestant unfortunately the
show was not a huge hit and wasn't
renewed for a second season at least he
could still team up with Mike Myers
again right when the evil Feud Mike
Myers brought the character of metalhead
TV host Wayne Campbell to Saturday Night
Live when he joined the cast in 1989 and
his chemistry with Dana Carvey seemed
natural but Harvey had a different take
on the relationship saying close we were
never meant to be a comedy team Mike
just invited me into the sketch I'm
grateful that he did and quote after
Wayne and Garth spawned a movie in 1992
and a sequel in 1993 Myers and Carvey
left SNL and everything was fine until
Myers wrote and starred in Austin Powers
international man of mystery in 1997 the
character of dr. evil played by Myers
was a parody of various James Bond
villains but his mannerisms closely
reflected those of SNL creator Lorne
Michaels or according to car V they more
specifically mirrored Carvey's
impression of Michaels which he do
around the offices of SNL Harvey was so
miffed at the comedic plagiarism that he
didn't talk to Myers for about a decade
but they've since made up appearing
together at multiple Wayne's World
anniversary screening dr. evil said it
best it's just so pathetic to see you
two fight over a silly comedy it's like
watching two bald men fight over a coup
in Paris
he's doing stand-up again Harvey is
mainly known as a sketch comedy
performer and actor in movies of varying
success but when he first got into show
business in the early 1980s it was as a
stand-up comedian
after leaving SNL he did stand-up here
and there taping a few specials but he
took a pretty long break before starring
in his first new special in nearly a
decade Dana Carvey straight white male
60
jon lovitz he's a comic in residence at
the foundry in las vegas where over the
course of 2017 he'll perform 20 shows of
stand-up comedy sketches and musical
numbers so if you don't see them in
movies or on TV you know where to find
them thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]